I think fans are really gonna be upset
after episode three what happens to miss
Cassandra I'm very heartbroken by it did
you know that was gonna happen coming
into this were you shocked by that
I knew yeah I knew and it was it made
sense for the story I love those like
did you see the terror on AMC they did a
similar thing we're like you're heading
in one direction on the storyline and
then you just go a completely different
direction
I love that in storytelling I think it's
really kind of like surprising and
spontaneous for the audience so
hopefully we kind of give a bit of that
flavor what do you have to say to the
fans who are going to be inevitably
devastated though I'm sorry and I hope
you keep watching because this is an
incredible incredible group of actors
and storytelling so happens under any
chance in a season two that your
character could come back whether it be
as like a flashback or a ghost er would
be your Christa's or question not one I
can answer you would do it though girl I
don't know what you tomorrow okay if you
watch the society you know it's Greg
Dewey who ends up being Cassandra's
murderer
I killed Cassandra for everyone
she had it coming this gives a lot of
other characters a lot of dynamic moves
now as to whether how they reacted it
was like this is a very pivotal thing in
our society today of if you look at the
politics of the capital punishment you
know there's a lot of stuff and so for
me to to do that I had to really kind of
change my thought process of why would
this guy do this the most heinous thing
you can think of and so it was kind of
weird getting to that spot having to try
to get my own mind okay what kind of
home life that this guy had is he just
trying to fit in with the guys and it's
just not a big deal to him maybe that's
where he thought and he just came out of
coma dining and in turn Ali makes the
call to have him killed as punishment
[Music]
it's like an eye for an eye really is
what happens do you think people are
gonna be upset with that or do you think
that was fair I think it's I don't know
it depends kind of how you view things
in your own life for me I think like
they'll definitely be some people that
are upset about it maybe because we are
kids but at the same time if I were
watching I'd be like oh yeah like see
how to come in but it it's a tough way
it is because if you're not talking
about something that there's no
consequences if someone's life but it's
both sides of the coin it gives it a lot
of tension
[Music]